mais vous ne vivez pas dans un abîme les
portes et les fenêtres ouvertes
et vous croisez français de vivre dans
un appartement avec les sacres et les
fenêtres de ernie els que les la peine
qu'on l'a de prétendus de prétendre des
frais mais pauvre les hôtels
particuliers à
singulièrement chaussons mais chassez
vide assure jean alors l'épisode je suis
né dans la ferme deux jours mais je m'en
moque de voter j'ai même au nez de tout
ce que je vois mais vous me sais que je
n'aurais pensé que de
la réalisation et c'est mon apparence
tout âge où on les attend à ce que je me
demande bien ce que c'est publics n'ont
que nous son avocat excusez moi de vous
dire que yassine est ce sondage été payé
par nicolas sarkozy est absolument
scandaleux air france de nicolas sarkozy
et je dis ce que je vous ai si j'ai
envie de mettre en cause de la collusion
entre le service public et prix on a
public je le fais je peux éventuellement
expliquer ici profiter de cette
invitation qui m'est fait d'expliquer
pourquoi vous êtes une imposture dans
cette élection dit mais je ne viendrai
pas avec vous parce que vous n'êtes pas
en état de combat 2d bars et pubs on va
peut-être vous n'êtes pas obligé d'être
agressif avec vous deux vous n'êtes pas
obligés de donner des ciseaux enquête
soit depuis des représentants abbas a
depuis tout à l'heure c'est vous et moi
je vais vous dire les prises et même
d'autant plus c'est d'autant plus facile
à voir que vous parlez de temps et qu'on
peut pas en plaçant livre vous êtes tout
en méprisant vous rend même plus compte
enfin oui écoutez vous êtes sans aller à
ces journées soient cotées cette
caractéristique permanente y insiste
agresser les autres des douze ans qu'on
se voyait fiction genre en cause est une
femme que je dis vous n'avez pas ici
monsieur parce que vous vous êtes couché
vous vous en brûlant des voitures
rexel vous vous couchez en permanence
vous êtes après l'autre en permanence
devant l'allemagne devant le syndicat
d'amérique devant lui au fief devant les
communautaristes suis devant les
puissances d'argent entre différents les
banques à plat ventre et madame le pen
candidat wrap l'avant je suis debout
mais pour être debout je n'ai pas besoin
de salir qu'est ce qui vous a fait
réagir c'est ce qu'a dit oui c'est de me
strauss kahn ce que on s'est regardé
après avec avec arlette chabot et
on s'est dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est parce qu'il a dit est en fait si
c'est ce qu'ils avaient dit oui bon bah
des années des années de combat
politique c'est vrai de prises de bec de
mai cette marine de conviction de cette
marine le pen l' offensive est
indicative on ne la voit plus
on n'entend plus comme ça est ce que la
partie en passer maintenant mais c'est
pas ça c'est que je pense qu'on se lasse
moi je me lasse de je les dis je me
lasse du bruit et de la fureur jeu
c'était pas facile c'était d'ailleurs
moins facile qu'aujourd'hui il faut être
honnête
on défend des idées qui n'était pas à la
mode à l'époque elles le sont devenus
depuis mais je pense qu'on mûrit voilà
je joue j'ai pu 30 jeunes et plus 30 ans
j'en ai plus 40 j'en ai aujourd'hui 53
je suis à ma troisième campagne
présidentielle j'ai envie de j'ai envie
d'efficacité aujourd'hui j'ai envie
d'aller au fond des choses
[Musique]